problema número 240 una mezcla de
semillas x tiene 40 por ciento de maíz
rojo y 60% de maíz blanco
la mezcla de semillas
tiene 25 por ciento de maíz rojo y 75
por ciento de frijol la mezcla de xy
tiene un 30 por ciento de maíz rojo cuál
porcentaje del peso de la mezcla viene
de x
anotemos los datos nos dicen que la
mezcla x tiene 40 por ciento de maíz
rojo y 60 por ciento de maíz blanco la
mezcla ya tiene 25 por ciento de maíz
rojo y 75 por ciento de frijol vamos a
llamarle a al porcentaje
de peso de la mezcla x
esto es lo que nos preguntan así que
cuál porcentaje de esa mezcla será de
maíz rojo que viene de la mezcla x bueno
la fracción de a que viene de x pues va
a tener un 40 por ciento de maíz rojo
todo esto es el maíz rojo de x y cuanto
más rojo tendremos de g
si ésta es el peso de la mezcla de x
entonces uno menos a será lo que viene
de ella y tiene el
25% de maíz rojo de g
esto es maíz rojo de g y nos dicen que
esto es igual a un 30% es igual a 0.3
vamos a despejar a esto es 0.4
y
0.25
menos
0.25 de a igual a punto 3 sumamos estas
as y nos va a quedar 0 punto
15.40 2.25 es punto 15 de a es igual a
punto 3 - punto
25.05 por lo que a va a ser igual a
0.05 entre
0.15 y esto lo podemos simplificar como
50 15 o también un tercio que esto es
igual a 33 un tercio como porcentaje y
esta es mi opción b siguiente problema
problemas 241 si el entero n tiene
exactamente tres divisores positivos 1x
n cuantos y visuales positivos tendrã n
al cuadrado bueno cómo es posible que un
número tenga una cantidad impar de
divisores supongamos que m
bueno los divisores de 6 son
16 y también tenemos
23 cada número tiene una cantidad par de
divisores como podemos tener un número
con divisores impares pues solo si uno
de ellos es el mismo número
si tenemos n sus divisores van a ser 1 n
iv en medio tendríamos x y x siendo el
mismo número está x lo que implica que
si tenemos un número impar de divisores
el número original es un cuadrado
perfecto ya que se está multiplicando
estos dos números que son iguales es un
cuadrado bueno claro que esto todo esto
es sólo para recordar antecedentes y no
es parte de la solución de lo que nos
preguntan sabemos que cualquier número
pequeño que sea un cuadrado perfecto
cumplirá con esto por ejemplo 4 cumple
con estos 4 tiene su divisor 1 sub
divisor 4 y también 2 y 2 2 por 2 son 4
así que sus divisores son 12 y cuatro
cuantos divisores tendrá su cuadrado el
cuadrado de cuatro que es 16 va a tener
uno va a tener 16 va a tener 28 y 4 va a
tener 5 factores y esta es la opción de
todo el análisis previo nos llevó a
encontrar que era un cuadrado perfecto y
sólo necesitábamos encontrar un cuadrado
pequeño para poner números y encontrar
la respuesta veamos el siguiente
problema problema número 242 tienes un
entero positivo entonces n por n más uno
por n 2 es viendo las opciones nos piden
que veamos qué pasa cuando en espa o
impar veamos qué pasa cuando en espacio
si es para quiere decir que es un 2 x
otro número n va a ser igual a 2 x otro
número que voy a llamar k vamos a
sustituir esto acá nos va a quedar en
buscar x
n
21 por n que es dos más dos vamos a
factorizar esto ya simplificar lo es
igual a 2 camps por 2k más 1 aquí factor
hicimos el 2 x
1 esto lo puedo sacar como 4cast por 2 k
más uno por cada más 1 y esto es
divisible entre 4 por esta parte y veo
que la opción es justamente dice que es
divisible entre 4 quien es padre
entonces la ecuación va a ser divisible
entre 4 que es mi opción el siguiente
problema problema 243 un tubo recto de 1
metro está marcado en cuartos y en
tercios si el tubo se va a cortar en
cada una de las marcas cuál de las
siguientes opciones tiene todas las
longitudes de las diferentes piezas en
fracciones de metros vamos a dibujar
nuestro tubo supongamos que es este
ahora vamos a hacer las divisiones
primero los cuartos que sería aquí más o
menos a la mitad luego la mitad de este
y la mitad de este otro y ahora en
tercios que ese día más o menos
algo así bueno vamos a hacer los cortes
este sería por acá éste acá y ahora los
de los cuartos bueno vemos que esta
parte de aquí va a ser igual a esta
parte de acá lo mismo los estos dos son
iguales esta parte cita de aquí va a ser
igual a esta de acá estas dos van a ser
iguales lo mismo sucede con esta y con
esta así que sólo tenemos que encontrar
las longitudes de estos tres pedazos y
encontraremos las longitudes de todas
las fracciones ok entonces vamos a
analizarlo quedamos que de aquí acá esta
parte de acá era un cuarto y todo esto
de acá desde aquí hasta acá es un tercio
bueno que será esto
esta parte va a ser un tercio menos un
cuarto la diferencia un tercio menos un
cuarto encontramos nuestro común
denominador 12 aquí va a hacer 4 por 14
menos 3 por 13
esto es igual a un 12 a esto de aquí es
un 2 ya muy bien ya encontramos este
pedacito ahora nos falta encontrar este
bueno de aquí acá hasta acá esto
quedamos que es un medio y esta parte de
aquí bueno ya habíamos visto que es un
tercio así que este pedacito de acá va a
ser un medio menos un tercio nuestro
común denominador 2 por 36 estos 3 menos
dos es igual a un sexto esto de aquí es
un sexto ya hemos visto que este es un
punto y esas son las mismas medidas que
tenemos en este otro lado ahora qué
opciones tienen un cuarto un medio y un
sexto y bueno pues tenemos que la opción
de tiene todas estos valores nuestra
opción es la d siguiente problema
problemas 244 si punto 0 0 15 x 10 l m
en 3.03 x 10 a la k es igual a 5 por 10
a la 7
cuánto vale m - k bueno vamos a hacer
esta división vamos a dividir 0 puntos 0
015 y agregó unos cuantos ceros acá que
los voy a necesitar entre puntos 0 3
para hacer la división necesito recorrer
a este punto dos lugares acá y si lo
hago aquí tengo que hacer lo mismo acá
así que el punto queda aquí y lo subo
ahora no hay ningún número que
multiplicado por 3 me dé 1 así que aquí
pongo un 0 y aquí pongo un 5 5 por 3 15
aquí queda la resta exacta y aquí tengo
una dirección exacta también así que
todo esto me queda como punto 0 5 por 10
y por las leyes de los exponentes va a
ser m menos acá y me dicen que esto es
igual a 5 por 10 a la 7 ok bueno vamos a
dividir todo en 3.05 me va a 10 por m
igual a 5 en 3.05 para hacer la división
tengo que recorrer este punto dos
lugares aquí también entonces si mi
punto está acá tengo que agregar dos
ceros para recorrerlo aquí y me va a
quedar ahora si uno por 55 la resta es
exacta tengo que subir estos dos ceros y
me queda que 100 10 a la m menos acá es
igual a 100 por 10 a las 7 pero estos no
se los puedo agregar aquí en el
exponente de manera que me queda 10 a la
m acá igual a 10 a la 9
entonces m menos acá va a ser igual a 9
m menos k es igual a 9 y esta es mi
opción y nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo